so I'm Saul Perlmutter and I'm a
professor of physics at the University
of California at Berkeley and also the
senior scientists at Lawrence Berkeley
National Laboratory the measurement that
we wanted to make the measurement that
we had set out to make was a measurement
of the history of the expansion of the
universe by seeing these very very
distant stars these exploding stars the
furthest one was so far away the flight
was travelling to us for some ten
billion years and fun to think about
what was going on while that light was
traveling to us so imagine this one
supernova exploding and this bit of
light starts to travel to you across
this expanding universe here where we
live today there was just a scattering
of dust that was starting to coalesce
into perhaps a disc and while all that
light travelled to us that disc warmed
eventually into a swirling mast where a
gay star formed in the middle and that
became our Sun and some of the outer
parts turned into planets and little by
little one of those planets you know
went through various different changes
and Jochen being hotter and colder and
meanwhile that photon is still
struggling to make its way across the
universe to find us life started to
appear and by now our lonely photon
that's still making its way across the
universe has shifted a little bit from
blue towards a slightly redder color and
that Poteau life evolved into more
complex life with more complex
multicellular organisms that swam around
the solutions and eventually into life
that rolled out onto the surface evolved
into different species eventually
mammals eventually us and so while this
is happening the photon is still
traveling to us we started to understand
this world and learn eventually how to
farm and eventually how to make tools
and and start to explore scientifically
well what is its world around us we
learn some technology so we just are
building things eventually we got the
point that we could build this largest
telescope we ever made and point it just
over
to that part of the sky where that same
photon that's been traveling for all
those ten billion years would fall into
the telescope and we would catch it and
that's how we've learned about this
universe that was all going on while we
didn't even exist yet
you
the beautiful bay above tree or Tree of
Life is an African icon the bail Bob
fruits contains four times the potassium
of banana three times the vitamin C of
an orange and twice the calcium of
spinach but the bail Bob is an orphan
science has paid little attention to
this tree until now the African orphan
crops consortium is harnessing the power
of genetics for orphan crops the bail
Bob tree is the first of 101 plants to
have its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient use sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture